bonjour alexis jours ravi de vous
retrouver dans la matinale de rtl france
alors on va parler de ce drame de cette
adolescente qui s'est suicidé à cause du
cyber harcèlement au delà du drame
personnel est ce que c'est un drame de
société oui alors c'est sûr que
rappelons la mémoire de cette jeune
fille dina qui avait 14 ans qui devait
souffler sa quinzième bougie le 18
novembre et qui n'a pas tenu deux ans de
harcèlement pas seulement cyber
harcèlement au quotidien elle était
scolarisée au collège emile zola dans la
banlieue de mulhouse et voilà que ses
bourreaux ont eu raison de sa joie de sa
détermination elle a mis fin à ses jours
début octobre et derrière ce drame
familial il ya un vrai sujet de société
parce que il y à plus d'un élève sur dix
qui est victime de harcèlement france on
estime que ces sept cent mille élèves 7
700 mille pardons élèves qui sont à
subir des insultes parfois de la
violence en france et on voit que c'est
un sujet récurrent mais qui n'est jamais
traité à la source c'est toujours la
victime qui doit changer d'établissement
qui est poursuivi par ses harceleurs là
une enquête est en cours on espère bien
sûr que ceux qui ont eu la bêtise et la
méchanceté de faire ça cette jeune fille
seront poursuivis à hauteur de ce qui y
est finalement le responsabilité et une
hutte la lutte contre le harcèlement m6
versement était une priorité du
quinquennat d' emmanuel macron qu'a t'il
vraiment fait finalement dans ce domaine
encore une priorité qui finit en
campagne de communication il ya une
vidéo sur ce match at des modèles macron
qui parlait aux élèves du harcèlement il
ya eu aussi brigitte macron qui avait
fait une vidéo fin 2020 disant que vous
pouvez compter sur ma détermination à
poursuivre ce combat et l'engagement
plein et entier du président de la
république
les enfants et les adolescents doivent
savoir qu'ils peuvent compter sur nous
et nous serons là pour eux on a vu alors
brigitte macro avaient reçu des lettres
de parents aussi en détresse elle avait
changé finalement le jeune loup casse en
janvier 2020 d'établissement mais encore
une fois cette solution de changer
d'établissement n'est pas une solution
et puis finalement tout le bilan du
quinquennat sur ce harcèlement scolaire
c'est des mesures héritées du
quinquennat hollande le numéro
vers bien sûr le 30 20 ou les appels ont
explosé 1,77 1742 sollicitations de ce
numéro 310 référent harcèlement on a
6281 ambassadeur collégiens et 3419
ambassadeur lycéens c'est à dire qu'on
demande aux enfants d'être ambassadeur
contre le harcèlement dans leur domaine
mais il faut rappeler les paroles de la
mer de dina qui disait que le corps
enseignant n'a rien fait pour ma fille
ils ont simplement dit c'est des
banalités qu'on échange entre copines
deux ans où le corps enseignant n'a rien
fait on se rappelle aussi bien sûr du
cadre ce professeur assassiné par le
djihadisme samuel patil là encore pas du
tout aidé par sa hiérarchie alors
jean-michel bancaire va sans doute
essayer de dire qu'il a fait de
formidable chose à part de la
communication et de l'agitation il n'y a
rien eu sur le harcèlement est
d'ailleurs ce problème de harcèlement et
de violence faite aux enfants n'est pas
du tout à la journée avait des candidats
à l'élection présidentielle on le voit
bien loin non les enfants parle très
rarement alors on parle un peu
d'éducation certes mais il faut voir que
même cette thématique du harcèlement
scolaire avant 2011 n'existe quasiment
pas dans les politiques publiques 1
c'est luc chatel qui le met à l'heure du
jour et puis ensuite on a eu quelques
mesures sous le quinquennat hollandais
ou continue à faire des mesurettes mais
on ne prend pas l'ampleur de ce
phénomène puisque derrière c'est une
violence endémique d'une société
violente mais sur les violences faites
aux enfants et la pédocriminalité en est
une hausse aucun candidat ne se
positionnent là dessus sauf georges
kuzmanovic sein qui a dit que lui
offrait une priorité si jamais il était
max havart d'ailleurs à 8 bon alors
voilà il pourra en parler mais c'est
important parce que c'est vraiment des
thèmes qui sont oubliés systématiquement
des législateurs les enfants placés
également liesse loufoque qui en parlent
beaucoup les lois ont été reculés c'est
à dire que là on a une assemblée qui
refusent même de légiférer sur cette
thématique là qui va prêter préféré
pardon montré du doigt la haine sur les
réseaux sociaux c'est à dire élargir le
débat pas seulement à la violence faite
aux enfants mais à la haine sur les
réseaux sociaux or c'est on le voit bien
des solutions qui sont des pansements
sur une jambe de bois au mieux il ya
vraiment rien fait je pense qu'il est
temps que les politiques prennent
l'ampleur de ce phénomène et que les
victimes innocentes cesse d'être
sacrifiée sur l'autel de la bêtise et de
la violence il nous reste quelques
minutes et pourtant et pourtant anne
hidalgo on l'a vu proposer le vote à
l'âge de saison donc ça devrait être un
thème réd porter bien sûr c'est un thème
porteur enfin au delà d'un thème porteur
ça devrait être un thème au centre d'une
société si la société faisait attention
aux personnes aujourd'hui on a quoi en
tête ah oui alors un candidat qui veut
remettre la circulation 90 km heure on
parle d'économie tout le temps on parle
d'emploi comme si les politiques
pouvaient faire quelque chose à la
conjecture économique très peu en
réalité on parle de nucléaire tout ce
qui est sur l'avenir d'un pays les
enfants on n'en parle pas pire encore le
taux de suicide des plus jeunes à cause
du coc vide qui a augmenté là encore on
met en doute certains chiffres qui sont
pourtant et puisque inquiétant et
aujourd'hui on a même certains
scientifiques qui à cause de l'explosion
des brocolis disque voilà vous savez si
vous occuper de votre bébé il faut
mettre un masque et éviter les contacts
donc on a vraiment dans l'irréel je
crois qu'on a à faire aussi à des
politiques qui ne connaissent pas
finalement la jeunesse les enjeux de
cette jeunesse et pourtant c'est
l'avenir d'un pays donc il serait temps
que ces sujets là reviennent au coeur de
la campagne c'est pour ça que je voulais
en parler ce matin merci beaucoup alexis
pour cet édito ce matin dans la matinale
rt france